we're on problem
problem 16. and they want to know what
is the area of the shaded square let me
shade it because they call it a shaded
square
so what's that area
so how can we do it
well it's a
it's it's a bit of a trick but what you
need to realize is
you could draw
let me draw some some things that might
this is actually a really fun problem
let me draw some interesting rectangles
here
draw a rectangle there
let me draw another rectangle
there
to
this really is just kind of a brain
teaser
another rectangle from there to there
and then let me just draw another
rectangle
from
there to there
okay so let me ask you a couple of
things
one
what is
what is the distance of the base of this
rectangle right here this distance
well we know this entire whoops wrong
tool we know this entire distance is
three right
because they tell us
oh they actually you know what they
don't even tell us they tell us that
this distance is one so we know that
this is a cube right that this distance
is three
so this distance is one
and then this distance down here is
three
and so and they tell us that this is a
shaded square right so all the sides of
this inner shape are also going to be
the same
so if this is 1 this is 2 then this is
also going to be 2
right
that's going to be 2 that's going to be
1.
that's going to be 1 this is going to be
1. i think you get what i'm saying right
and what is what is the distances of
this smaller square inside of here
well if this distance is one
if this distance is one from here to
here
this distance is also going to be 1
because 1 plus 1 is 2. that's 1.
same reason you can make the same
argument this is 1 this is 1 this is 1.
so the area of this small square in
inside what's the area of that small
square
what's the area of the magenta square
that i just
filled in well that area is going to be
1 right the magenta square is 1. so now
all we have to figure out is the area of
these these
these four yellow triangles and what are
areas of each of those yellow triangles
well each of those yellow triangles are
they have a dimension on the long side
the dimension is two
let me find a good color on the long
side the dimension is two
right this distance right here
is two
and the short side the distance is one
so it's area each yellow triangle is two
times one times one one-half right
because area of a triangle is area
equals one-half
base times height so area of each of
those triangles is so the triangles is
going to be one-half
times two times one
so that equals one right
so we have so this the area of this
triangle is one there this triangle is
one there this triangle is one the area
this triangle is one and then the area
of this square inside is also one so
it's one plus one plus one plus one plus
one the total area is five area equals
five that was pretty neat i guess
and and the big thing you need to
realize is that you could you can split
up
the uh the square on the inside like
this
let me think of if there was another way
that we could have yeah that's the way
that that occurred to me maybe there is
another way
maybe i'm over complicating it i don't
know but it looks nice
next problem
for all positive integers j j and k let
j i like these where they define new
math operations
j square with an r inside of it k
be defined as the whole number remainder
when j is divided by k so this equals
remainder
when j is divided by k if you're
familiar with the concept of a modulus
that's essentially what this operation
is
if 13
13 i guess we'll call this
remainder
remainder operation k
is equal to 2
what is the value of k
so and they tell us in the beginning
that j
and k all of these things have to be
positive numbers right so this is
essentially saying that when i divide 13
divided by some positive number
the remainder
i get a remainder
of
2.
well what number when i divide into 13
gets 2. well i guess another way to
think about it is 13 minus 2 is a
multiple of this number right
so you could say you know what's 13
minus 2 well it's 11.
so 11 is a multiple of k
and actually 11 should be k
because i mean f 11 is a
a multiple of k and and you know 11 is
not a multiple of much right eleven's
only a multiple of one and eleven so k
has to be eleven
and you can test it out i mean if you
get confused just try out different
numbers but
eleven thirteen divided by eleven is
equal to one right because 11 goes to 13
one time remainder
remainder 2
which satisfies this 13
remainder 11 is equal to 2.
next problem
problem 18.
the average of the test scores of a
class of p students is 70. the average
is 70. so what do we know about that we
know that if we were to add up all of
the p students
well actually let me let me read the
problem before i do anything
and the average of the test scores of a
class of n students is 72 is 92. when
the scores of both classes are combined
the average the average score is 86 what
is the value of p over n
okay
so
what is the sum
of
of the p student scores
so their average is 70 so their sum the
sum of all of their scores is going to
be
p right you can take the average and
multiply it by the number of students
and then you get
the sum of all of their scores right and
if that doesn't make a lot of sense
think about it what's the definition of
the average is the sum
that's just the same because the sum
divided by p
is equal to the average
right
so if you multiply both sides by p you
get the sum
is equal to p times the average
and the in this case the average is 70.
so 70 times p is the sum of the first
class and then what's the sum of the
second class
it's going to be 92n for the same exact
reason
and now how many total students are we
averaging well there are p in this sum
and they're n in this sum so it's p plus
n
and they tell us
that this average score is 86
so we've set up our equation and now
let's solve let's multiply both sides by
p plus n
so you get 70
p
plus
n is equal to
p
plus 86 n right p plus n times 86
distribute the 86.
now what do we want to do we eventually
want to figure out p divided by n so
let's put the n's on the left-hand side
so i'm going to subtract 86 from both
86n from both sides so you get
70p
plus 92 minus 86 is 6n
is equal to 86p
right i subtracted this from the other
side
and then let's subtract 70p from both
sides so you get 6 n is equal to 16 p
right 86 minus 70.
and then we want to know p
divided by n
p divided by n so if we divide both
sides by n you get 6 is equal to 16 p
over n
and now divide both sides by 16 you get
6 over 16 is equal to p over n
and of course we can reduce 6 over 16.
6 over 16 is the same thing as 3 over 8.
that is our answer for p over n
i'll see in the next section